it is III 2017 my name is Jake and I'm
here with Jason and we're about to take
a look at a game called Road Redemption
let's get into it so I mean the first
thing that a lot of people noticed is
that it is very similar to Road Rash I
take it you guys sands of that game very
much so yes the game is very much
inspired by Road Rash and really when we
started the game that's what we want to
do is bring back Road Rash it's funny
because this game has a huge following
still Road Rash does so and people have
wanted a game like this for so long so
it's really cool that there finally is a
game like yeah absolutely
certainly you know lots of lots of fans
or still reminiscent of the the old Road
Rash games and you know I myself was a
huge fan on the Sega Genesis so
certainly you know that's that's our
biggest audience I also noticed too that
there's split-screen right off the bat
which is which is cool there is yeah
it's a four player split-screen a full
co-op campaign mode as well as a
competitive mode as well
so what what differentiates the campaign
mode from from the racing is there is
there a story going through towards
their different levels yep so there's a
story then with voice acting and
characters that you encounter along the
way there's also various different
missions that you encounter of different
types of missions with each level that
you have to do more than just a race
sometimes there's takedowns or beat the
clock and different ways that different
gameplay experiences throughout the
campaign and it's still found this work
good yep so each level has various
shortcuts that you can and different
alternate paths and sometimes the the
other enemies will follow you that way
as well so I noticed there's a lot of
motorcyclists driving around with like
almost little icons over their head or
is that like pickups essentially yeah so
the the ones with the icons over their
head are special to have special drops
so they'll give you extra cash or extra
nitros yes you have to knock them off
their bike and yes I like that that's
cool
it's also looks is this post-apocalyptic
maybe or is this just it is yes as a
post-apocalyptic world a little bit of
sci-fi you know this particular you know
inspired by Mad Max a little bit yeah
this particular scene and as you
progress through the game you encounter
some other more sci-fi characters as
well do you pick up different weapons
you do so we have a variety different
weapons you know everything from this
pipe that you see here to satisfying
this samurai sword and machete and then
we also have ranged weapons we have
pistols automatics guns explosives
grenade launchers pipe bombs so as you
progress through the campaign you can
actually upgrade your weapons and you
get bigger and better weapons that's
cool it's violent - yeah so you know
coming from the original Road Rash we've
decided you know to amp up the violence
yeah but it's certainly a lot more
violence
I know there's still police though
that's supposed to bother ya these
police aren't your average joes though
they're out to get everybody police are
always fighting so it's kind of so this
is a race and those are the people
you've eliminated along the way down the
corner right yes so yeah at the bottom
it shows you your kind of progress
towards the race and certainly if as you
kill your participants in the race you
could you know if you're the last man
standing then your win you win by is
that mechanic and multiplayer as well
like if I'm playing with you and you
kill me am I out the rest of the race or
do I get to come back it is yes and in
the campaign mode
you can actually be resurrected at the
end of the the level and then here you
see the our store so between each
mission in the campaign mode you have
the opportunity to spend your cash to
buy upgrades pyramids you know replenish
your health with you know steroids and
various things
like the voice-acting - yeah voice
acting is good and yeah we've got a you
know basically at the beginning and end
of each mission you get some some bit of
the story and then also as you're
playing through you'll get some various
dialogues from some of the characters
that do cars try to mess you up - it was
like that car tried to slam against you
yeah some of the cars are aggressive and
will try to take you out so this one is
in a race this is so this is a time
trial yeah I trying to beat the clock
so in these types of missions you
normally get a little bit more
aggressive combat and they try to
prevent you from making it to the finish
line alive so as you as you progress
through this story are there we're there
other locales other than deserts or is
it mostly sticking to the deserts yeah
so we have three main territories where
you encounter three different gangs and
so each territory has its own theme
first one being the desert then we also
have a winter and a sort of a desolate
post-apocalyptic city as well that you
encounter and each one gets
progressively more difficult with with
enemies getting stronger and each each
gang just more out to get you I'm
guessing driving in the city is a little
bit tougher as well - tighter corners
and not as much space - yeah there's
more more buildings on the on the
outside Peter run into and a little bit
more going on and we also have a
rooftops where you actually drive along
on the rooftops probably our most
difficult level where you have to
prevent yourself from falling off and
falling to your death
yeah I rip the voice-acting I definitely
get that Mad Max beautiful
Sandy's there's pickups on this
particular mission I get a sticky bomb
no cool see if I can catch up to
somebody and blow them up so it started
you intent right so you gather yeah you
always start in the back and I have to
work your way up
[Music]
these said some some of the levels you
have the trucks that are actually in the
race these guys you got to take them out
or so try to see them
[Music]
this is do you do you aim it or is it
you have to like kind of a line you're
driving behind it there is aiming so you
have full control over your with the
right analog or the mouse if you're in
muscle keyboard and then we have a
little bit of auto aim so makes a little
bit easier because it can be difficult
to both drive and shoot but certainly
the the guns can be a little bit
overpowered so the challenge of actually
aiming and and shooting makes it a
little bit more balanced yeah that is
always one of the tougher things the
doing games shooting
[Music]
so we do allow you to venture off a
little bit up up the hills and mountains
times you got to find your way back to
the road another sharp cuts oh no this
one's a little more dangerous
[Music]
what is the benefit of taking out those
cards so they're part of the race just
another and then also they were really
try to wreck you so and you can't can't
beat them as easily with a baseball bat
so it's normally better take them out
with with a bomb or with the gun can you
aim for tires and they would know but
you know as you shoot them they'll
slowly start to start smoking and kind
of explode once you once you finish them
off show you another feature is our grab
here if I can get a hold of somebody
grab along and run them into something
something oh man I missed it
that's all right I'll get on with a pipe
bomb
also head slam them
it's so satisfiying I'm not even playing
and it just seems so satisfying
[Music]
this games been in development for quite
a while huh yeah we've been developing
over three years now and so we've been
been in early access on Steam for quite
a while and so we're now finally trying
to finish up the development we got our
our last big feature is it's going to be
a online multiplayer a 16 player
competitive multiplayer mode online so
that's been in private beta and and hope
to release that very soon once it's
polished up
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like this game in particular
would be very tough to talk and conduct
an inner-tube interview always pretty
intense
[Music]
I'll show you our critical attacks as
you as you fight you build up your
critical attack meter and can oh maybe I
won't show you though they are very
aggressive
you mostly just you mostly get cash from
knocking people off their bikes and
completing missions yes so yeah each
mission has a cash prize and so
certainly the better you do in the
mission the more cash you'll get so if
you get first place in a race you'll get
more does it rest even if you don't get
first it does so yeah we have a keeps
progressing even when you lose the
missions but there are penalties for for
failing okay
see I need to buy some health here how
long does it take to run three then yeah
if you play if you play through without
losing you could actually beat it in
about an hour okay but doing that is
quite the challenge so the game is built
to be randomized and played through from
the beginning and each time you play
it's a random experience and between
playthroughs you have a skill tree that
you can unlock new abilities new bikes
and new things that will help you
complete the campaign do those carry
over to multiplayer or is that only
funnel into campaign so that's in the
campaign in the multiplayer we're going
to have its own progression system where
there will be leveling and unlocks we
better unlock new characters and weapons
and bikes
[Music]
they're very aggressive what is is the
blue that is your nitro that is a nitro
yes does it recover over time or do you
have to it recovers as you kill enemies
no you get a small amount of nature and
health and we also have pickups that you
can get to get more nitro or through the
store you can purchase more and so you
know one of the strategies for winning
the race would be to you know user nitro
and then take out a few enemies to get
more nitro back and then and continue
along to try to get speed boosts that
way
second right up there sly can take them
out almost
Oh ran out of ammo is it the
old-fashioned way
should be better at this
like I said interviewing and playing is
probably very difficult especially with
this game third place creeping up on you
too yeah you have to get at least
they're better to not get penalized so
you don't want to be in fourth place
what are the penalties it's a health
penalty so you get your max health gets
reduced took out third place and then we
also have a campaign plus mode after you
have beat the the normal campaign
unlocks campaign Plus which has even
more difficult missions and even harsher
penalties but uh but your your skill
tree does carry over into campaign Plus
so you can continue to to build your
power that way and in order to beat that
although it's fairly difficult mode cool
well this is road Redemption thank you
Jason for stopping by and showing us
this is very excited to play this with
some friends and people in the office I
think that'll be a fun split-screen game
is there anything like that please you
know we're on Steam so you go ahead if
you're interested in the game you like
what you see please check us out and
check us out on Steam cool and if you're
back home thank you for watching if you
want to see more videos like this make
sure to subscribe we have tons of
content from e3 we've got all sorts of
different games make sure to check that
out until next time